J'ai trouvé une dernière bobine de la
série " voir l'invisible "
donc voilà c'est la dernière de l'été,  bon
visionnage !
Bienvenue fidèles spectatrices et spectateurs.
dans ce nouvel épisode d'écorce de recherche
consacré au monde mystérieux
de l'invisible.
Avez-vous vu les mouvements de l'air
provoqués par mes gesticulations ?
Non, car l'air est parfaitement
transparent.
Est-ce que vous arrivez à voir les
turbulences provoquées
lorsque j'ajoute de l'eau salée à de
l'eau douce ?
Non, car l'eau est également
un milieu parfaitement transparent,
et accessoirement cette tasse est opaque.
Dans un milieu comme l'eau ou bien l'air,
les ondes lumineuses se propagent de la même manière
qu'elles arrivent par ici ou par là
ou bien par ici
et même par là.
Ainsi pour les scientifiques,
ces milieux sont dits isotropes.
"Iso" signifie "même"
"trope" direction.
Sachez que l'analyse de la
structure des objets isotropes
a longtemps posé problème aux
scientifiques,
mais vous l'aurez deviné, ils ont trouvé
une solution
particulièrement astucieuse
et esthétique.
Il s'agit de l'observation en contraste
inférentiel à polarisation,
ou plus simplement...
il n'y a pas plus simple !
Il s'agit de l'observation
en contraste inférentiel à polarisation.
Regardez ces images, produites dans les
laboratoires de l'institut d'optique
théorique et appliquée.
Ce que vous venez de voir c'est la
surface de l'eau qui se déforme
en présence d'une tige
et ses images psychédéliques ont été obtenues
grâce à l'imagerie en contraste inférentiel
à polarisation.
Comment fonctionne cette surprenante technique ?
Comme son nom l'indique, les contrastes de couleurs
sont obtenus suite à l'interférence de
la lumière.
Rappelez-vous :
La lumière blanche se décompose en longueurs d'ondes
qui elles, sont responsables
des couleurs que nous percevons.
Lorsqu'un rayon lumineux
traverse certains cristaux
comme le quartz, il se sépare en deux rayons.
Si, avant ce cristal, on place un objet,
son image va se dédoubler
et l'une de ces images sera un peu ralentie
par rapport à l'autre.
Les ondes lumineuses
produites vont alors pouvoir interférer.
Cela signifie qu'elles vont
interagir pour créer des ondes lumineuses
soit avec une plus grande
intensité
et on appelle cela interférence constructive,
soit avec une plus faible intensité,
et on appelle ça
des interférences destructives.
L'éclairage se fait en lumière blanche,
donc avec toutes les couleurs.
Certaines couleurs interfèrent
constructivement, d'autres destructivement.
Autrement dit, certaines couleurs vont
disparaître alors que d'autres vont rester.
Et qu'en-est-il de la polarisation me direz vous ?
Et bien nous n'allons pas rentrer dans les détails
mais sachez que la polarisation est une
propriété particulière de la lumière
qui est en quelque sorte filtrée par le cristal
pour donner les deux images à la sortie.
Cette technique nous permet de
visualiser des objets à faible contraste
ou des variations d'épaisseur d'objets
transparents.
Un exemple :
Cher ami, prenez donc une plaque de verre !
Le verre est parfaitement transparent et
parfaitement lisse,
en apparence.
Pourriez vous bouger légèrement la plaque ?
Voyez : les infimes irrégularités
d'épaisseur se traduisent par de vives couleurs.
Merci mon ami.
Maintenant, prenez donc une bougie.
Cette technique permet également de
visualiser les mouvements de l'air.
Observons les courants de convection
autour de la flamme de la bougie.
Bravo, c'est très réussi.
Et ce n'est pas tout :
Cette technique permet aux chercheurs
d'étudier nombre d'autres phénomènes
comme par exemple
la flottaison de petits animaux à la
surface de l'eau.
Qui ne s'est jamais ému
face aux prouesses gracieuses de ces petits insectes
qui dansent à la surface de l'étang,
dans une chorégraphie tant silencieuse qu'improvisée ?
Comme vous avez pu le voir,
nos chercheurs ont
réussi à rendre cette observation
encore plus magique
grâce aux contrastes de
couleurs obtenus
suite à l'interférence de la lumière.
Cette technique est donc d'une très grande utilité
pour les biologistes, les physiciens
qui étudient la mécanique des fluides
et bien évidemment les artistes
qui désirent voir le monde autrement.
Ainsi, ce n'est pas un hasard si
imagerie en contraste inférentiel à polarisation
rime avec poésie fantasque,
essentielle à la  vulgarisation.
Et pour vous abonner, c'est par là
et par là aussi
également par là.
Et par là.